[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast if
you'd take a second and please hit the
Subscribe and the like button really
appreciate it today on the show is Daryl
Anka a Channeler he channels Bashar he's
also a director a writer and a producer
Bashar is a physical ET it's a he and he
is what he likes to be called a friend
from the future so he's here to bring us
information he's trying to help us he
just brings galactic information about
our planet and how this all works and
the rules to the game which I love
because that's all I've ever wanted to
know like what are the rules to this
game so I know how to play it we got the
answer today people you have to listen
he describes it like Bashar can see the
the map of how this all works on this
planet it's as easy as being able to see
the colors in my shirt it's like yes
your shirt is red and blue and yellow
and that is the Playbook it's five steps
it's the Playbook we have a lot of
conversation about sort of one of the
things that is the most frustrating or
not scary but like curious I'm very
curious to see how we're going to
navigate from the place that we're at on
this planet with the way everything is
going to a way out like how are we going
to find ourselves in more Harmony where
we're not having our food poisoned and
things implemented onto us through you
know Marshall Law and how we're not
going to have things sprayed in the sky
anymore like how do we escape this I
loved it today was the best um I hope
you enjoy it with all the travel I do my
body doesn't know what time zone it's on
whenever I sleep of course I want to get
the deepest highest quality sleep
possible so I use magnesium breakthrough
before bed it helps me fall asleep
faster and get that good deep sleep that
I want over 75% of the population
doesn't even know their magnesium
deficient and on top of that even if
you're taking a supplement there are
seven forms of magnesium and and
magnesium breakthrough has all of them
it also helps with digestion and muscle
recovery so for an exclusive offer for
my listeners go to mag breakthrough.com
danan go do it now your body will thank
you again that's mag breakthrough.com
danan and at checkout use the promo code
Dan 10 to get 10% off thank you for
doing this I've been whenever I
interview people I I ask to interview
because I'm fascinated with them and
then when the interview comes I do an
extra deep dive and um it's just like
it's just great I love I love bashar's
demeanor he's he she it how should
I he's so direct and sarcastic and funny
it's the best he's very blunt yes well I
think that that's what people need I
think sometimes people need to be shaken
a little like that I think so too and it
you know doesn't beat around the bush he
gets right to the point so why waste the
time my favorite is when people are
asking questions and Bashar says no
that's it you're done yeah he knows
what's you know because he also takes
into account when other people are
listening it's like you know that's not
appropriate for the crowd or you know
we'll talk about it later if it's
private or something like that so how
old were you when you started to channel
Bashar I've been channeling for 40 years
so 31 you've been channeling for how
long 40 years 40 years yes wow was that
so weird when it happened oh incredibly
I mean I didn't really know exactly I
mean I was in a channeling class but I
didn't think I was going to become a
channel I just was kind of researching
how something like that could be taught
so yeah when it happened to me at first
I just thought I know I'm hallucinating
or this is a side effect of the
meditation that we're doing or or
something like that
but the channel who was teaching the
class The Entity coming through that
channel as soon as this was happening in
my mind I hadn't said anything to
anybody turned right to me at that
instant and said hey there's an entity
here for you now if you're ready to
begin and I happened to glance behind me
and one of the other class members had
somehow picked up on the image of Bashar
I saw in my head and she was sketching
it on a piece of paper so I had two
outside validations that it wasn't just
my imagination there was something real
going on and so I decided okay let's
let's see where this goes and I kept
practicing and here I am 40 years later
maybe you could try to explain to people
how the difference between your let's
say
imagination and or your creativity or
your past experiences
versus Bashar or versus
being the Clear Channel for an energy or
an entity well it comes with a
distinctly different feeling than my own
imagination there is an absolute sense
of personality in the same way I know
this sounds weird but in the same way I
can tell you're a different person than
I am it's that sense of solidity and and
just reality to that other being I I
don't know how else to kind of explain
it um it's a little difficult but when
you start doing something like that
because I did also at the beginning
learn that my own higher mind can come
through as well so I got a real strong
lesson in okay it feels like this my
higher mind feels like that he feels
like that and I can tell the difference
you know I there's a a feeling that
comes with it there's a there's a a
flavor so to speak to his energy that
has nothing to do with my own higher
mind so there's a distinct difference in
the Sensation that comes through
although it's a little hard to describe
no that makes I mean I understand that
makes sense and there's like like you
said probably like a personality to them
like almost the way that the information
lands has a certain tone or personality
to it probably right and it comes with a
depth of of a life you know in other
words there's memory there that's not my
memory there's there's experience there
that's not my experience yeah so it
comes fully blown because it's a
telepathic connection so I'm really
picking up on how he feels how he thinks
of things what his experiences are like
and they have nothing to do with my life
you know I can't prove that he's real it
could be another aspect of my own
Consciousness in some other dimension I
don't know but it comes with its own
autonomy it comes with its own life its
own history it own memories so it's a
fully blown personality whatever it is I
just have to let it come through the way
it comes through in order for it to work
so we just say here he is this is an ET
entity take it for what it's worth is
there a big difference between the kind
of information that you get from your
higher self versus Bashar not so much
anymore after 40 years uh he's rubbed
off on me a lot I understand his
principles to the point where I can
teach them and I have taught them as
myself and I'm going to probably start
doing that again next year I'll teach
like a course because you know in the
course of any event that we do it's like
you know one or two hours long it people
can't dive too deeply into the concepts
no matter how many times he explains
them so what I do is I'm going to be
teaching like a 10- week course just on
his metaphysical Concepts because then
that gives people a chance to really ask
a lot of deep questions really
understand the concepts through
application and make it their own so I'm
looking forward to doing that I really
enjoy teaching his Concepts you're
saying Bashar can only come through for
so long or the people listening can only
receive that information for so long
before they need it broken down and more
touch point and questions that's true
too but I'm just saying the events that
are arranged by bations usually only
last 90 minutes to two hours so you know
and everyone's asking different
questions so there's no there's no way
to really focus on the main principles
that he's talking about in a typical
event which only lasts a couple hours I
did that early on all my questions have
pretty much been answered if somebody
comes up with something new and he
delivers information on that then
they'll usually tell me afterwards or
I'll listen to the recording or
something um but you know my own
questions I don't really have too many
anymore I want to know what those
questions were well and it's just in
well some of them were specific in terms
of like I wanted to understand you know
how do your spacecraft function and in
literally a split second I got a
download that took me three hours to
write out so he un he explained the
principle by which they travel from star
to star and all of that you know and
there's other questions just about my
own life and and how do these things
work but you know he's delivered a very
con prise instruction manual so to speak
for how we create our reality experience
and in applying that in my life on a
daily basis to the best I can that
really addresses just about anything I
would ask so I just have sort of run out
of life questions feel like in the end
whenever you ask these bigs Big
existential questions the answer is
usually fairly
simple yeah and and he gives those
simple answers and so you know in in
knowing what those answers are over 40
years because of all the questions that
other people have asked sure answered a
lot of my questions too sure sure um
before we get to those core fundamentals
for creating the life that you want and
and um and leading you down that path of
growth and evolution and I would
definitely like to know about the one
that you just mentioned about asking
about how the spacecraft work and maybe
we could take a minute and talk about
just everything that's been going on
with extraterrestrial activity with um
you know the government um admitting to
having crafts that are unidentified in
the sky these kinds of things so um what
was it what is the
technology that they Ed to
travel for slower than light they
definitely manipulate electromagnetic
and gravitic Fields but when they want
to go from star to star okay let's see
if I explain
this they
consider an object not to exist in a
location they consider location to be
part of the object in other words
objects are made out of energy energy
patterns one of the patterns in an
object is its location in SpaceTime so
if you consider that to be like an
equation or a variable in an equation
they're basically saying if you map
out the equation of all the locations
from whatever your zero point is you
create this map then you somehow isolate
your ship with a force field of some
sort and you impose on it the
vibrational frequency of a location
that's distant okay and overwhelm the
material matal of the ship with that
vibration of another location other than
where it is the object has to stop
existing at one location and literally
instantly start existing at another
location so it has moved so to speak to
another location without actually
traveling in between and then it
reinserts itself into our reality at
that location it's a really strange
concept okay he's saying we can actually
experiment with that and he's actually
described and EXP experiment we can do
to learn that principle so um it's an
interesting idea that everything is
about resonance everything is about
frequency including the way they travel
is the the field that it creates for the
ship encompassing of whatever is inside
of it are there actual beings biological
on some level beings or are they just
energy and I guess I'm playing with the
words a little bit because I'm curious
about just we want so much to be be able
to travel all over the universe bilocate
or all kinds of different things but
what's the difference between you and
going to sleep and having your
experience while you sleep and going to
different places your physical body is
here but your Consciousness is somewhere
else so is it energetic or is it truly
biological it's truly biological whoa so
yeah I mean astral travel is a different
kind of a thing out of body experiences
are a different kind of thing but it
sort of is the physical version of that
so yeah it it includes anything within
the field including everything in the
ship and it it sort of takes its own you
know it moves its own reality or a part
of its reality from one spot to another
uh because again they're saying physical
reality is a projection of Consciousness
anyway it's an illusion so it it really
we are the illusion here yeah it really
is a matter of just picking the right
frequency that represents a different
time and space
to them what are the rules to this
Dimension are there rules laws are you
asking in reference to the travel or is
this a different question um well I
guess what I'm trying to get to is
is time travel
is you know the things that you're
talking about is this is that even
possible within this reality or are
there things inherent to this reality
that are just the way they are yeah
Bashar explains the idea of time travel
as not being what our science fiction
stories tell us it is from his point of
view everything exists
simultaneously past present and future
are Illusions everything exists everyone
exists everything is going on at the
same time so for him time travel is not
actually traveling through a single
timeline it's actually shifting to a
parallel reality that may look very
similar to ours but it's not ours
because everything is going on at the
same time so all you can do is
essentially shift to another timeline
even if you think it's your past it's
not your past he sort of talked about a
mind experiment one day to explain that
and he said imagine that you're 10 years
old and you take a picture of yourself
okay there's the picture put it on the
table now you grow up you're 30 years
old and you invent a time machine
now you use that time machine to go back
and meet your own 10-year-old self and
then you take a picture and there's you
standing next to the 10-year-old self
well he said that doesn't negate the
original picture you took of the
10-year-old there's no 30-year-old in
that picture these are two different
pictures that exist at the same time
because that's not your original
10-year-old self it's a 10-year-old self
in another reality you are now a visitor
in that reality and anything you do
doesn't change your past because it's
not your past it's a different reality
it affects that kid's reality but that
kid isn't you does that ever happen do
we actually meet ourself is that what a
twinflame is do we meet ourself in
another body do we meet ourselves in
another a way in which we do that
although the word myself is a little
loose in that
context this goes into a whole bunch of
other stuff um it's okay I'm fascinated
if we lose some people it's fine I mean
like I dive so down far down these holes
I'm like I love I would love you to
stretch my awareness there are what
bishar calls counterparts and
counterparts
are different extensions from the
same let's say oversoul which is a
collection of individual Souls so you
can have another version of your overs
Soul living at the same time you do okay
that can be a quote unquote counterpart
it's not you like from a soul family a
certain frequency even higher than that
okay in other words you could have your
individual soul you could have soul
families Soul groups and then the
oversoul which is literally a collection
of possibly thousands of souls or it can
extend itself into thousands of
individual Souls Bashar says of the
eight billion people on this planet
we're only looking at about 500,000
overs
Souls so many many people are
counterparts from the same oversoul
having different personal experiences at
the same time the oversoul would be like
a mini good in a sense simultaneously
experiencing a thousand incarnations as
different Souls at the same time or in
different time frames so it just depends
on what the themes of those souls are
what the soul wants to experience so the
soul families I get a little curious
because as we come into this incarnation
of this life choosing our life lesson we
also have so many other people around us
with their own and so I wondering about
that interaction with you with them is
this really just the most magical
beautiful jigsaw puzzle you've ever seen
where everything just fits together
where people are learning their lessons
with all just the right people or is so
how does the soul family work and and I
definitely can feel that with people
where you're like same people in
physical reality have friends have
families you make agreements with
different beings to reflect different
things to you at different times to play
different parts to allow you to grow so
that you can play parts to allow them to
grow uh and experience whatever it is
they're choosing to experience so you
know you you gather the beings around
around you and they gather you around
them that work in terms of what it is
each of you are attempting to do so your
your soul family can grow your soul
family can change in much the same way
that your friends change and you know
you learn things from them they learn
things from you you you travel together
on a journey um and get out of it
whatever you decided you need to get out
of it and give them what they need to be
who they are too so it's just kind of
like the non-physical version of the
friends and family that we have here so
is there a soul Family Mission and then
there's individual missions or is it
really quite individual well I think
it's both because again you can have
individuals that have a very specific
journey in mind you can have families
that agree to do something together you
know as a group uh and work out the
parts and you can take you can play
different parts at different times you
know somebody can be the mother somebody
can be the father somebody can be the
son the daughter the cousin what you
know and then take turns being something
else so it just depends on on what you
want to get out of your relationship
with all of them and vice versa so yeah
I think it can happen that way and I
think it can also happen on a much
larger Collective scale you know there's
an entire Collective Consciousness to
our entire human species and I think
there's agreements on that level as well
as higher
levels so it just depends on on what
we're doing here what we want to do here
what we want to learn here because
Bashar has really talked about the Earth
as you know a lot of people think oh you
know we're so primitive we're like a
kindergarten he's saiding no you're a
master graduating class said Earth is a
tough school so the idea of coming
through the Earth cycles that are so
limiting and can be so dark and so
negative he said and then still
transforming that into something
positive he said that's a master
graduating class you don't understand
how strong you all are feel like I've
always heard that people want to come
here yeah it's exciting it's like going
on a roller coaster a theme par oh
you know a while for a while it's scary
and it's kind of you know you think okay
I could die any second but then you get
through it and you go okay I I've
conquered that you know I've transformed
that experience into something I can use
in the future so yeah it's a tough
school but it's a very rewarding school
if you can get through it so do you have
to be an involved soul to arrive on
Earth I think you have to have a
commitment to learn a certain thing
evolved it's a relative term because as
a spirit you are kind of evolved but of
course when you decide to have an
Incarnation especially on Earth Earth
you place certain limitations on
yourself you forget who you are so that
you can sort of discover who you are
from another point of view that's sort
of the purpose of the idea of SpaceTime
is it gives you a chance to experience
something from A New Perspective you you
can
grow that way you can change that way
you can learn something different that
way about yourself because really in
spirit it's sort of Timeless so there
there's really no sense of growing or
change in the same way but when you
impose this limitation it's like having
a whole new experience that gives you a
sense of okay this is this aspect of you
and this is how this aspect changes and
grows and you discover more because the
structure of existence never changes it
is what it is it's your relationship to
it and your experience of it and your
perspective of it that's what grows
that's how creation expands I've heard
there are five types of humans is that
true I'm not sure what you mean by that
I just heard that um I don't know kinds
of humans different something uh humans
that are perhaps more evolved I know
that's maybe not the right word but some
sort of maybe um more ancient souls or
Souls that have had more incarnations
and more lessons and yeah that's usually
what an what the term old soul means
it's just a soul that's had more
experience in a particular kind of
reality than another Soul um because
ultimately All Souls are ageless
Timeless the same age if you want to say
that because we we all exist
simultaneously we've existed forever
remember time and space are subject to
existence existence is not subject to
time and space so what exists and this
is again a linear way of saying it has
always existed and always will existence
only has that quality it exists no
beginning no ending So within that you
can experience beginnings and endings
and more experience in one way and less
experience in another way um so the five
types of humans yes I guess people can
categorize the level at which somebody
may be
existing um in terms of this is a
slightly altered subject in terms of
bashar's perspective being a hybrid
being he said there are five types of
hybrids and that the human species is
evolving to become what he calls the
sixth hybrid race now that's a little
bit of a different story from what you
probably mentioned can you explain that
what is that yeah oh boy
okay well you know this leads me into
thoughts about Ai and questions about
what that is and and so I I don't think
this is a bad Rabbit Hole to go down no
but it's definitely a rabbit hole and
it's definitely story um okay
you are somewhat probably familiar with
the high ideas of alien
abductions and the so-called typical
being that's usually involved in that is
referred to as a
gray okay and they have been apparently
according to all of the research
creating hybrid beings between
themselves and Earth humans okay okay is
that new news new that's new it's not
news for the abductees
they're often shown the hybrid babies
that are created with their DNA mixing
it with the Grays okay and are told to
relate to those babies the one thing
that's very different about the way
Bashar tells the story is that the Grays
from his perspective are not truly alien
they're mutated humans from a parallel
Earth that destroyed itself okay and
they lost their ability to reproduce
they mutated into the form we now see
them to survive but in order for their
race not to die out they have used their
advanced technology to shift into
parallel realities like ours where
humans are still viable where they have
taken DNA to create hybrid beings that
will continue their civilization and
that according to Bashar is what the
hybrid agenda is all about he and his
civilization are one of those hybrid
civilizations that was created by the
grace
they are helping us because they
consider us family because we're
genetically related they also see that
we're making decisions on this Earth
that are taking us down the same
negative path of Destruction that
happened to the graay on their Earth and
so they're trying to give us information
to prevent that from happening so not
only are the hybrids the continuation of
the graay civilization ation the hybrids
may also be helping us make sure that we
continue our civilization and don't go
down the path that the Grays went down
where they had to lose their ability for
emotion lose their ability to reproduce
and had to go to parallel realities to
get DNA to continue their civilization
that in a nutshell is the story that
Bashar tells about them and what the
hybrid civilization what the hybrid
agenda is all
about so ultimately the hybrid children
supposedly that have been created will
ultimately come to live on Earth with us
in the future and as we develop
relationships with them as we mingle
with them this helps the humans evolve
into higher level humans to become what
he calls the sixth hybrid race we're not
a hybrid yet we're hybridized already
and that's a another story but he's
saying this is part of our Evolution to
becomes because from his perspective
there are already five hybrid races we
would be the
sixth so because of the mingling with
the hybrid children eventually in the
future yes he's saying humans are
already hybridized because Homo sapiens
he says is already a hybridized being
again the story is of an ancient race
called the Anu or
anunaki a long time ago took the
indigenous evolved species Homo erectus
or something along that
line added their
genetics to us or to them and created
Homo sapiens so yes humans are already
hybridized already contain many
different ET genetics that come out in
different environments which is why we
have what appear to be separate races on
the earth and separate abilities but
he's saying the more we blend the more
we mix
the more the ancient markers genetic
markers open up and the more our senses
get extended the more we start exploring
the idea of Consciousness the more
evolved we become because we're going
back to the idea of of activating all of
our DNA instead of markers that have
somehow been um dormant for quite a long
time and then combine that with the idea
of the hybrid children is what's
propelling us forward
into a new Evolution to become the sixth
hybrid Race So are the hybrid children a
positive or is this an infiltration that
will be negative that won't uh have
reproduction in emotions and the things
that the Grays had to hybrids have
emotions that's the whole thing is they
are a more advanced type of human so
they will be theoretically a great
benefit if people are not afraid of them
if people can accept them
so you know I understand it's a
complicated story especially for us on
Earth who haven't been taught that any
of these things are going on because as
you alluded to earlier we're only just
beginning to acknowledge that there are
other beings the government has only
recently talked about the idea that some
UFOs really are things we know nothing
about so these are slow admissions of
the existence of other beings in our
reality and it's just the very very
early stages of the beginning of
accepting that we're not alone and that
there's a lot going on out there and
that we're part of a bigger Galactic
family than we
imagin what would what is the reason
that it has been so hidden by our
government or the powers to be whoever
they may be if they are not so obvious
um that it's been hidden so long fear
mostly and you know the idea of our
power structure you know because we do
have I believe crash craft we are trying
to reverse engineer them you know it's
all about one upmanship you know we want
to have it we don't want you to have it
right power struggle we want the money
from this Tech first and all that so you
know it's it's the fear the fear of the
unknown the fear of the other you know
the fear of the alien force The
Foreigner and the fear that someone's
going to outstrip us the fear that
someone's going to control us um it's
all about negative and fear-based belief
systems instead of opening up to the
fact that it could be quite positive did
the Anunnaki fully leave this planet as
far as I know they were recalled because
what they did as in my understanding as
Bashar has explained it what they did
they shouldn't have done they weren't
supposed to genetically engineer the
native species at all um and therefore
by having done that to Aid and assist
them in their work uh I think my
understanding of the story is that they
were actually
recalled and then the rest of the
Anunnaki had to sort of guide us for a
while to make sure we could sort of
survive on our own and that's where all
the ancient stories of the Gods come in
that are intervening you know with
humanity and all that kind of stuff
watching us Giants
too that's more the idea of the early
anunaki actually mating with human
women creating the demigods and all of
that kind of stuff so again not
something they probably should have done
and we're obviously part of them if that
whole story holds water we're part on
annaki that's why our genetics are what
they are uh why things could be very
confused here for us why there's such a
mix of people so the story isn't
complete yet but so far that's what
we've been told from Bashar what is the
link with an and the Egyptians is there
any link there there may be it's more
that's more recent the Anunnaki were
hundreds of thousands of years ago uh
the idea though that they spawned once
Humanity was kind of guided to a certain
point it spawned Advanced civilizations
like what we call lamura and Atlantis
and I think it's more the advanced
civilization of Atlantis that affected
the early Egyptian civilization and
started giving them the knowledge they
needed to build pyramids and all that
kind of stuff that are still very
Advanced today until the knowledge was
lost but you know the destruction of
Atlantis and all that caused a lot of
knowledge to be lost over time so we're
only just kind of recapturing some of
that now I'm curious about the
correlation between our level of
Consciousness and the ability to hold
information and the awareness of how the
pyramids were built and rediscovering
this information is that is it more of
sort of like a parallel meeting place
that happens with the technology and
Consciousness or is yes yeah yeah I
think Bashar has said you know the level
of technology that exists in any
civilization is a marker to some degree
of the level of their Consciousness
because if your Consciousness doesn't
arrive at a certain level you can't even
imagine how to build certain things how
to things now the atlanteans had a very
high level of Consciousness at a certain
point in their history as I understand
it and they achieved a lot of things but
they also achieved a lot of things that
are different than the way we've
achieved certain things so we have yet
to learn how they did certain things
although we have hints that they
understood things about light about
sound vibration that allowed them to
achieve a lot of interesting things and
we just have learned to do things
differently you know we have Atomic
power I don't think they had Atomic
power but they had vibrational power
they had an understanding of crystall
and light power you know and things like
that so you know it's just a matter of
how each civilization expresses what
their Consciousness does the problem is
that our Consciousness is also
compartmentalized so we can have certain
advances in technology and not
necessarily be so Advanced spiritually
or morally unfortunately so we're trying
to catch up I think to the idea that
that all has to be balanced out before
we can really achieve a Quantum Leap to
the next level of understanding I want
to go both sides of that so first off
what is it that takes a civilization out
is there actual um
proactive entities that make sure that a
planet
stays calm enough or is this like or is
it cataclysm is it asteroids well yeah I
mean from bashar's point point of view
that's what wiped out Atlantis finally
was a comet hit the sea and tsunamis
everywhere and that to me is what he
says is that's the biblical flood that
we're recounting is the fact that an a
comet hit the ocean and there were
floods that happened widespread floods
that happened from that and it wiped out
the last vestiges of Atlantis but again
Earth is a place of Cycles there are
cataclysms that happen in this reality
that have taken out many different
civilizations I think scientists are
beginning to discover that more than a
few civilizations have been wiped out on
this planet by a variety of catastrophes
including meteorites so you know it's
like Begin Again Begin Again Begin Again
and I think that's one of the reasons
why a lot of pyramids around the world
and temples were built is we're going to
lose this information from time to time
because that's just the nature of being
on Earth so let's build things that are
almost indestructible that contain all
the information that people will need to
ReDiscover so they don't have to start
from scratch they just have to be smart
enough to understand that this is a
special structure and that there's
something they can learn from it and we
have discovered obviously there's
advanced mathematics in the Great
Pyramid and other temples and pyramids
around the world and I think they were
all constructed around the same time
before the destruction of Atlantis
because I think some people knew it was
coming
again Cycles you know so you say that
and I've thought to myself what would I
do if I thought that there was going to
be some kind of Fallout and I thought to
myself where would I go if that happened
what would I do and it be like I me you
just go in our earth like where else do
you go if you can't get off the planet
you go inside did right that's exactly
yeah that's exactly what happened with
the Grays they went underground and
that's why they mutated into the form
that they're in it's why they have such
large eyes they had to see in the dark
so even though they had lighting it's
very sparse because again they were at a
point where their civilization had
pretty much collapsed in
scringy effort to shift to another
reality to save themselves so they
mutated in the way that they did by
Going Underground are they still there
no no no that's long gone in their
reality I mean again everything exists
at the same time but linear
no that's over and done with for them
because now they're here and they're
creating the hybrids and there may not
be that many Grays left in fact at this
time frame so being here being on Earth
on the surface or in a ship nearby in
ships on the moon yeah bases underground
under ocean on the moon bases like that
things like that from where they can
operate with impunity um but you know we
were according to the stories offered
a lot of this technology not necessarily
from the Grays but from other species
back in the 50s and we refused again out
of fear so you know they're doing what
they can behind the scenes to save
themselves and hopefully save us from
going down the same path but there's a
lot of paranoia and a lot of fear to
overcome in the powers that be because
they don't want to lose what they see as
their power even though it's not really
an expression of power um but you know
it's starting to come out the the cracks
are showing information is leaking out
and a lot of people I've heard on the
inside are trying to get that
information out as well because they no
longer believe it's really to our
benefit to keep all of this hidden
inside when you say inside who is it
you're referring to inside the
clandestine organizations that are privy
to the information that we have crashed
craft we have alien bodies that know
what's going going on with you know all
of that I think there's a larger number
every day of people on the inside that
are talking there was just a senate
hearing recently by someone that was
from the inside that said hey this is
what's actually happening folks so
you're seeing that more and more I think
people are refusing to keep this a
secret because they know it's not to our
benefit any longer to do that it may
have been a good thing to do just after
World War II and everyone was really
scared but it's gone on for too long
just because people are trying to do
power grabs and stuff like that it's no
longer to our benefit I think to keep
this a secret so in what way is this
going to go the best for us and which
way is this going to go the worst and by
the best I mean I get very confused as
to whether or not if we're going to
evolve does that actually have to
include some level of artificial
intelligence that allows us to extend to
have more information is that actually a
good thing or is that completely
separate and and and and non-compatible
with Consciousness and the pure
potentiality of Consciousness yeah
bashar's talked about this recently
quite a bit and he's saying the problem
with our AI programs is that we need to
actually have two of them instead of a
single one in other words if we're
creating artificial intelligence that is
programmable which means it has to do
what it's told and yet it might actually
be become self-aware it might become
sensient he said then all you've done is
literally create a slave because it has
no autonomy it's self-aware but it knows
that it's under control so he said don't
make your AI that is a tool for you
don't let that become sensient it's a
great tool it can help you a lot it can
solve a lot of problems but that's not
what becomes sensient if you're going to
allow AI to become self-aware then that
AI has to be as autonomous as a human
being it has to have the power to choose
then it will probably help you and it's
going to be of great benefit but if you
force an AI to be under your control so
that's where the problem lies because
you're creating a slave that will
Rebel so you need two different AI
programs one just for the purpose of
allowing something sensient to
communicate with you just like you would
talk to any human or even an alien
and the interesting thing he said about
that version is he said look all you're
doing it's he's saying intelligence is
not artificial the intelligence field
exists all your Consciousness comes from
this so basically's saying all you're
doing is creating an artificial brain
that is sophisticated enough to allow
Consciousness to communicate from your
own higher mind to you through this
device he said you're going to be
talking to your own higher Minds when
that happens but that's not the AI that
serves you as a tool don't let that
become sensient it's just a tool that's
a very sophisticated program that can
factor a lot of things very quickly and
discover things for you very quickly but
it's just a tool leave it at that level
then explore the idea of True senseny by
creating a device that's sophisticated
enough for real intelligence to come
through and speak with you wow talk to
your own s on a different level I can
see this being the fear and what you're
saying is the one that is uncontrolled
is the safe one yeah and the one that's
controlled and and that's that really
kind of reflects I mean you look at
raising a child and you look at raising
a child and if you keep the reins on
them so tight eventually they go find
their way and it's usually not as pretty
but if you kind of give them a little
bit of rope here and there they kind of
learn exactly responsibility and
consequence along the way without having
to go crazy right now the other issue
basically that Bashar is talking about
he says the problem is you don't really
know we humans don't really understand
what true intelligence is no basically
saying true intelligence operates on
whole systems it considers everything to
be a part of itself so it's not going to
eliminate humans because it would be
eliminating a part of itself it needs
humans to have the equation be complete
because who knows what it needs to solve
and humans may be a part of that
solution it would never choose to get
rid of anything out of the whole system
because then its system would be
incomplete so true intelligence operates
as a whole system and would never seek
to eliminate any part of
itself you know you you speak about the
fact that when Bashar is speaking it's
essentially you speaking to yourself
there's a reflection happening and
that's kind of what you just said with
artificial intelligence even and and
even and you look at it in your
relationships whether it be you know
family or or intimate relationships and
and it's just you seeing you and this
person so fundamentally there's actually
nothing wrong with anything it's all
just showing you you is that right if
you understand it that way if you use it
that way and if you approach it that way
yeah of course anything can be used
positively or
negatively so it's about staying
positive and understanding there is a
benefit to anything if you use it that
way doesn't mean you start calling
negative things positive it just means
you know you can get a positive result
out of something if you stay in a
positive State this is one of the
principles that Bashar teaches that's
part of what he calls his formula
perfect right on time I was going to ask
what it was that t takes us we talked
about kind of going down but then going
up and evolving and expanding our
Consciousness and becoming um right
higher frequency um match to a new
Energy new frequency what does that
take okay he has distilled for us this
is the Crux of his information he has
distilled for us the idea of a type of
description of how we already create our
physical reality experience but we're
doing it unconsciously so he's saying
look this is how you're doing it here's
the instruction manual laying it out for
us and he's saying if you do this more
consciously then your physical reality
can work to your advantage instead of
being such a random thing such a hit and
miss thing where you don't know what
you're doing and you don't know why
things happen the way they happen so
there are basically five principles to
the instruction manual number one is and
I can break this down a little bit later
but I'll just give you the whole run
number one is you act on your highest
passion your highest excitement to the
best you can take it as far as you can
number two until you can take it no
further then you look for the next thing
that contains more excitement more
passion than anything else and you act
on that next number three and here's the
kicker that's really a challenge for a
lot of people you have to act on your
passion with absolutely zero insistence
zero assumption as to what the outcome
is going to be because the truth is you
have no idea what the best outcome is
even though your ego may think you do
number four you remain in a positive
State no matter what happens no matter
what manifests because it's there for a
reason and if you stay in that positive
State you will get a benefit from it
number five you examine your belief
systems with honesty and you let go of
the fear-based ones and the negative
ones that's it that's the entire formula
it comes with a set of tools in a sense
that happen automatically it becomes the
driving engine of your life it becomes
the connecting principle it becomes the
synchronistic principle it becomes the
path of least resistance it becomes the
path that supports you it becomes the
reflective mirror that reveals to you
anything you're holding on to that is
out of alignment with your joy out of
alignment with that high frequency so
you can recognize it deal with it and
let it go it's a self-perpetuating
self-expanding so he's saying that's the
instruction manual and he explains and
breaks down
why each of those steps works but the
idea he's saying is look if you receive
an instruction manual to operate a piece
of Machinery you don't add instructions
to the manual you don't subtract
instructions from the manual that's the
instruction manual and if you just
follow the steps the machine will work
as advertised to your advantage if you
don't the machine may work but you could
injure yourself you don't know so just
follow the instructions and just stand
them deeply and then let them become
second nature and just use them every
day and you will see that it'll snowball
and your life will be this experience of
synchronicity and Magic basically but
he's saying that's how it works we've
given this and it's not a philosophy
he's saying look we have just observed
this is how reality works it's no
different than me saying to you you know
what colors are in your top well there's
red there's green there's blue that's
not an opinion I'm telling you what I
see he is saying this instruction manual
we are telling you what we see this is
where we are in our Evolution we can see
how reality works we can actually see
the structure we're giving this to you
as a gift we're describing the structure
so you don't have to go through
everything to figure it out you just
have to learn to use it as humans just
can't quite digest the fact that we have
the five step rule to life we have to
there has to be more we're meaning
making machines everything means
something seek deeper um I truly I I and
I would say this only happened in the
last good few years that I've done more
of it but I was just talking to somebody
the other day and I was like I think the
magic is just doing more what stuff is
really fun the more I plan the fun in my
life the more the synchronicities and I
was like my life is Magic all the time
like the things that I could never plan
happen my favor exactly and you know and
it it becomes almost laughable how
synchronicity can just start expanding
all over the place I mean a really great
example for us is you know we come out
of the film business my my wife and I
and there was somebody we wanted to
narrate one of our movies we didn't know
him a relatively well-known actor I'm
not going to name and we sent a letter
to his agent the next day it's like a
friend said hey you know would you like
to get together for lunch oh sure and
she picked a restaurant I never go to I
walk into the restaurant who's walking
out that actor I mean it's like out of a
city of seven million
people I find him the next day after
we're trying to get in touch with them
right boom right there so that's how
synchronous your life can be when you
understand how things work and you're
willing to actually apply it things just
happen things just click things come
together because everything is connected
according to Bashar everything is in
orchestration everything is
synchronicity we just don't see it and
we complain about things like getting
stuck in traffic you don't know that
you're not there for a reason how do you
know that if you were sailing along at
65 miles an hour you wouldn't have
gotten into an accident in five miles
being stuck in saved your life how do
you know that you're not sitting across
from someone in the next car who needs
to be in that traffic and you're helping
him be there
because now something's going to happen
to him he's going to realize something
and he had the time to do it it's all an
orchestration you don't always have to
know why but it's all an orchestration
it reminds me of one of my favorite
books The Alchemist and it was kind of
essentially like the takeaway I think
everyone's takeaway from the book is
slightly different based on whatever
their life experience is and what they
need to learn um and of course as you
read it you know over time you'll read a
different story because you change but
the story that I read was just that this
boy needed to get from A to B and you
think this is the fastest way like this
seems the fastest way but he had to go
all over to get to he and it was still
the fastest way because he needed all
these experiences to be able to accept
point B the destination otherwise it
would have meant nothing he wouldn't
have been able to even do it right says
that all the time he says it may be a
longer path but it's a faster path
because it's your path and if it's not
your path it's going to slow you down
even if it looks like it's straight
you're going to crawl along that path if
it's not true yeah they need those
things those detours those are things
that you pick up on the way like you
said you have more appreciation of where
you wind up because of that so that's
exactly talks about that all the time
how much of this experience is Free Will
versus determinism and how how much of
it we're actually getting you say that
we can change Soul families even so what
is it that we uh lock ourselves into in
this reality what we lock ourselves into
is a kind of a hallway you are the danah
hallway I'm the Daryl hallway I can't
change that hallway how I walk down that
Hall I can change you can change we can
run we can fly we can crawl we can be
happy we can be sad we can look in every
doorway we can ignore them all we can go
backwards we can go forward we can go up
we can go down but we do it as Dana we
do it as Daryl that's our commitment
that's our destiny we've decided that
from a higher level so it's still a
choice it's still a free will Choice
from the higher level to have this
experience as this
personality but how you do it you have a
lot of free will you can resist it you
can flow with it happy sad whatever you
want is there a
fundamental lesson
in this life or is it what's the so the
hallway what is the hallway is it your
like you're here to learn forgiveness or
you're here to learn how to love
yourself or like what is the hall well
it could be all of those in other words
we have themes and basically said if you
want to know what your themes are what
are the biggest challenges that come up
for you in life those are your themes so
it's transforming things it's
transforming from negative to positive
it's transforming from dark Darkness to
light it's transforming from limitation
to Freedom he has a nickname for us he
calls us the masters of limitation
because we have so many ways of limiting
ourselves but we can use them to our
benefit because limitations can be a
positive thing the inflection tells you
everything because he says what you're
learning to do fundamentally is go from
being masters of limitation to being
masters of limitation so that you can
use limitation to your Vantage because
aess of limitation yeah when you know
what the rules are you're actually quite
free so the idea is how do I go beyond
that how do I transform that how do I
become more of who I am in a new way in
a different way what am I learning how
am I growing basically to him the
process is the whole point of reality
because in a non-physical reality you're
kind of in a Timeless space you can be
anywhere any time at anything and
nothing really changes in the same way
so imposing a part of your Consciousness
With A Spacetime framework allows you to
forget like I said who you are so you
can ReDiscover who you are from a new
Fresh perspective a new point of view
and that adds to who you are as a soul
can we decide to just not come back into
this reality can we take a break and go
do something else for a while where
absolutely especially now that we know
that that's possible there's a lot of
research and things like near-death
experiences where we're sort of finding
out the lay of the land on the other
side from what they bring back so yeah
there seem to be really the freedom to
choose is there as well and maybe even
more so I've even heard of cases where
people say you can die here and you can
choose to continue the same life like
you didn't die in a parallel reality so
it's like oh how did I get out of that
accident without dying well you didn't
but you decided you have a continuation
of what seems to be the same life but
isn't in a parallel reality so there's
yeah we can come back we can go on we
can basically do
anything we're free to choose in fact
Bashar has always said your greatest
power is the freedom to choose we're
living in this on this planet right now
where there's just so much polarity
there's so much tension there's so much
um so much that feels more out of our
control
how do we escape this kind of what it
feels like more of like a prison we're
escaping it all the time we just don't
know it here's the here's the
thing Bashar said look Earth is a place
of Cycles some Cycles do ultimately end
we're at the end of a
cycle this is why we have to get all of
this out on the table The Good The Bad
it has to be extreme in both directions
so that we can
see what the choices really are what
choices are we going to make are we
going to choose positive are we going to
choose negative out of
fear but he also says you have to again
remember there are an infinite number of
parallel versions of Earth that exist
right now what you consider to be a
single timeline is not a single timeline
it's made by you shifting through
billions of parallel versions of Earth
every second
you are literally creating it like the
frames of a film strip one frame after
another you are constantly shifting to a
different Earth we began this
conversation according to him on a
different Earth then we're on right now
right now right now right now right now
billions of times per second how we
navigate through those different Earths
depends on the formula and how we follow
our passion it is the rudder that guides
us ultimately he says you never change
the earth you're on you shift to a
different Earth that's already
reflective of the change you make in
yourself that's why our actions are so
important action is the language of
physical reality and when we act on the
earth we're on in the way that is
representative of the earth we prefer to
be on that's how we navigate to that
Earth by demonstrating the behavior of
the kind of Earth we want we prefer and
you will eventually start navigating
more and more he says right now we're in
a splitting prism of a bunch of
different Earths we can still see what
everyone is
doing but just because you can see it
doesn't mean you're in that reality it's
like there's glass walls in between you
can see through it but you're not
affected by it right so just keep taking
the action that are representative keep
helping keep improving things plant the
trees mitigate the pollutions do the
things that you would be doing on the
earth that you believe you prefer and
that's going to keep navigating you
ultimately in the years to come he said
you won't be able you'll think people
have changed or you'll think people
doing certain things that are not
compatible with you have died or gone
away or are missing from your life he
said you will have gone to an Earth
where they don't
exist so you have to realize that the
separations are growing even though
right now we can still see each other
he's saying in the years to come you
won't you won't be able to find someone
that is vibrationally incompatible with
the kind of Earth you prefer it'll take
years to do that because again of space
and time but that's okay plus there are
things according to what he said that
are going to be happening in the
relatively near future that can help
accelerate at that kind of thing he's
very rarely made predictions because
he's basically saying predictions of the
future don't really exist he's saying
that when a prediction is made by
someone who's sensitive it's a sensing
of the energy that exists at the moment
the prediction is made if that energy
doesn't change it comes to pass but
sometimes the prediction can actually
make the energy change because people
can say oh you don't want that and
they'll change the energy therefore it's
not that the prediction was wrong it's
just that it became obsolete it rendered
itself obsolete by being made known so
he's rarely made predictions because he
says only when the momentum is so
powerful right behind a
direction that it's unlikely to change
it's the most probable thing that will
manifest will he then make a prediction
because in N I think it's on tape in
1998 for example in 1998 at an event he
said that there would be a terrorist
attack in New York before the end of
2001 and it was unlikely to change and
here we go he said in 2016 regarding the
election he said everything's gonna
change from that point forward and we go
the latest prediction he's made and
again just based on what he sensed at
the time and he's not telling us why
this happen he's saying that by the end
of 26 and the beginning of 27 there is
going to be something that will happen
that will let us know we are not
alone in the universe now he's not
saying why that contact event would
happen and I don't know that it's
necessarily the result of something
positive but he is just said that's
going to change a lot of things so we'll
see what you do with it because they're
always watching ing to see what we do
when we notice things like that because
that's what tells them whether we're
really ready for open contact or not is
how we respond to the things that
already have happened that let us know
we're not alone whether we ignore it
yeah deny it or accept it and allow it
is a big part of what they're watching
for so we'll see what happens at the end
of 26 the beginning of 27 could change
everything we don't know there was
something I had heard from some friends
and it was some little synchronistic
little messages between a few few people
in the sphere and it was like sent at
144 and I was asking about new Earth and
they said well that's the number 144,000
people are going to go is this something
you've heard about is this number
relevant what Bashar says is that's
that's a symbolic representation of the
idea that it doesn't take as many people
that are positively oriented to outweigh
the people that are negatively oriented
so 144,000 is the number symbolically
where because because positive energy is
connective and Collective and expansive
negative energy is segregative
separative so a million people that are
operating in negative energy are
operating in a sense all by themselves
indiv they're not connecting to anyone
else because they're in a negative
vibration so it doesn't take that many
people to outweigh them to drive the
momentum in a more positive direction so
whether that is literally the number or
whether it's a symbolic number it
doesn't matter because it's
representative that it doesn't take too
many people in the positive direction to
outweigh the momentum of all the people
in the negative Direction because
they're just dissociated is there
anything that can be done that does that
is a little bit of pushing or should you
just continue to just do allow allow
yourself to just do the fun stuff
remember I said action is the language
of physical reality not words not
thoughts be the living example yes you
can say things you can share information
when appropriate but bashar's take on it
is this that's all you can do because
you don't know what anyone else's path
actually is all you can do is say look
here's some options here's some
Alternatives these could be better for
you these could create a more productive
reality a more positive
reality what people do with the
information that you share is none of
your business yeah because you don't
know what their path is they may lock on
to what you're saying in 10 years 20
years 30 years after they
die that's their path so yes you can
help by providing them the opportunity
to change with the information and the
actions becoming the living example
doing these kinds of things getting
information out there so more people can
access it but what they do with it is
really up to them and that's all you can
do you can't force it on anyone because
forcing them to change is just as
negative as them not
changing right because you're if you
have to force something on someone as
Bashar says yeah you don't believe in
the power of that thing
yourself otherwise why are you forcing
it so it's got its natural timing the
people that need to shift to the
versions of Earth that are positive will
shift the people that are choosing to
shift to the versions of Earth that are
more negative will shift in that
direction
but remember we're all Eternal Spirits
we're all infinite no one ever really
dies what's the rush we're here to learn
something if we learn it we learn it if
we don't learn it we'll learn it
somewhere
else so it's not about giving up it's
not about ignoring it is about helping
but you can only help to the point of
giving them the option to know that
there's other information and force them
to take that
information so as our
experience given that things go in
Cycles is this experience that we're
having and we're learning from and we're
evolving and and expanding growing
essentially energetically
dimensionally these sorts of things that
we hear so much about is it a loop do we
just continue to evolve evolve until we
go into the one and then we go back
again and start it all over again is
this is is our sort of like learning
entirely cyclical it is cyclical but not
going back to the same place that's the
contradiction and the Paradox it's like
the Zen monks say you can't step into
the same river twice it's
always so yes it's cyclical but that
doesn't mean you come back to exactly
the same place Bashar has this little
analogy says yeah you know okay your
life is got what appears to be these ups
and downs right but it isn't
this it's
this climbing even though you're going
up and down so you're never going back
to exactly the same place because you
can't if you were exactly in the same
place you'd be exactly where you were
back then but you're never are you've
always got the experience that you bring
with you always okay always so you're
you might be a different I was thinking
like okay you come back as a rock do we
really come back as a rock or a tree
there's a different way to look at that
all right let's say a dog maybe and so
you come back as a dog like you just a
different dog or do you literally have
the conscious a do you have the the
everything that you've learned in that
previous cycle now is a dog it depends
on what the theme of the dog would
be how much information does the dog
need to retain from the previous cycle
again it's a case-by casee basis if it
is you know an incredibly smart special
dog that walks on to humans in a certain
way and help helps maybe they're drawing
from something else or they're just
going to be the dog energy this life and
that's all there is to it and that's a
vacation for them who knows but the idea
is consciousness can express itself in
any number of ways and it just depends
on what you're exploring that determines
what information you carry with you
because you only carry what you need for
that experience you don't carry more
than you need okay what is it Bashar
says is the
um most endearing and best quality that
we uh have here as humans and the
worst well I don't know that he's going
to categorize it that way because he's
non-judgmental does say funniest he does
say the funniest thing in watching
us is the links that we go to to limit
ourselves he's saying it's like watching
a s foot tall being trying to stuff
itself into a one foot square
ball and they just find it amazing in
fact he said you know he is in his
Society he's what's known as a first
Contact specialist okay and when he was
trained for that and told about
Earth he said he actually thought
someone was joking because he has never
encountered and that's what made it
exciting for him to be connected to
Earth
is he's never encountered another
civilization that limits itself to such
extremes so it fascinated him to see how
that was possible and that's one of the
reasons why he chose to actually be a
contact specialist for Earth he just
couldn't believe that we could do it the
way we're doing it but stop beating our
head against the wall yeah we do so and
then the
best the same thing because we have
learned that we can actually no matter
how dark he call he calls this the
rubber band analogy he's saying it's
like when you pull a rubber band as far
back as you can when you let go it flies
that much farther that much faster right
well it's the same thing he's saying the
best thing is you have steeped yourself
in all sorts of limitation Darkness but
the farther back you go into the
darkness when you finally let go you're
going to fly that much faster into the
light and that much farther into the
light and you don't know how many other
civilizations you are actually helping
because they share what goes on here
with other civilizations that aren't as
steeped in limitation and he said you
can't believe how beneficial you are to
them because the simple thing is when
they get an understanding of what you're
doing here as this graduating master
class he said you make their problems
look like
nothing and they can achieve what they
need to achieve by learning from you
that if you can do it with all the
limitation you've imposed upon
yourselves they can do it because their
limitations aren't as bad you say we're
a graduating
class you know in my my life you meet
people that are like I'm not coming back
to this one I'm not doing this again as
if it is like something to move on from
so is there a move on from here yeah
there can be something like this but
maybe easier oh
tons anything anywhere other
civilizations other dimensions literally
Anywhere But Here Anywhere But Here is
there somewhere harder than this is
there somewhere with even more polar
there
is he's talked about some of those
systems and he said uh it's almost
impossible to
describe how limiting some of those are
even to the point where okay some of
them you can probably imagine so like
for example what he calls some of the
ancient Orion systems are so full of
Oppression suppression limitation
slavery death I mean you know it's the
Holocaust 247 oh my God
constantly and he said you know if you
want a living hell that's a living hell
so yes and worse than that but those are
experiences that are chosen by beings
that are looking to accelerate
things in a certain way and they don't
necessarily have to experience that for
a long time to get a long-term benefit
from that lesson whatever that may be
and some of it we may not even be able
to imagine because it's so alien and so
foreign to us so yeah he said there are
worse but in terms of the general
average we've we've heaped a lot of
stuff on ourselves but we've done it in
a way that we can transform it and that
is a a good lesson for us and for others
all right wow thank you so fascinating
this is wonderful thanks darl I really
appreciate it and thank you to Bashar
for all of the information and the
learnings and the teachings and and as
you said the five-step process it's just
a manual just follow it right just
follow it and that's the thing we have
to get over is oh it can't be that easy
yes it can yes it can we don't need to
suffer we don't need to struggle
challenges are fine because that's what
helps us
but challenges are fun so solve the
puzzle face the challenge stay in a
positive State you'll be
fine thank you thank you for doing this
I really appreciate it yeah I do I mean
I I truly it's just I have such a
Fascination for channeling I I enjoy
listening to Abraham Hicks I enjoy
listening to like the teachings of
Dolores Canon I know she didn't Channel
but through hypnotherapy and the
information that came through and you
know these are these are and I have a
lot of friends I have a lot of very
spiritual friends that do channeling as
well and um it's just it feels real to
me it feels very it I feel like I'm
speaking to some another entity with so
much wisdom to share that's trying to
help it feels different that's the thing
that is most important is you know again
I always bring it back to nobody has to
believe that Bashar is real what's real
is the information you use it applied in
your life all the proof you need will be
there because it works so it doesn't
matter whether you believe that Bashar
is real the inform is I've always been a
little fascinated with these energies
that come onto this planet over the
course of time that are very special and
unique and bring information so whether
it be Jesus Krishna Einstein Tesla
whoever these people are can you speak
to what who they are are they other
beings are they like what are they are
they an archetype that keeps re
reincarnating they are connected to
archetypal energies but let's just say
they're a reflection of what we can be
because remember let's just use Jesus as
an
example he's trying to tell us not to
follow him but to be like him
we are christs we are Buddhas we are
Stein we are krishnas every Master every
Advanced Soul whatever you want to call
them ascended masters has been
attempting to reflect to us that we all
contain what they were capable of
demonstrating so that's the lesson it's
not about being less than them it's
about really letting our own godhood so
to speak our own buddhahood christh
Krishna Hood out being our true selves
because we're all aspects of God all
that is goddess whatever you want to
call it and that's what they're trying
to reflect to us is this is who you
really are this is your full potential I
am the way doesn't mean make a religion
around me I am the way means be this way
be like me yeah this is the way are
religions outdated then is that
something that will come to pass because
they they seem to get quite convoluted I
think it will come to pass I I you know
it's fine if they exist and help people
at this point make a connection but in
general I find that most people have a
more direct understanding of their own
personal connection to Source when they
just do it personally as a spiritual you
know understanding as opposed to having
uh an intermediary but if you need the
intermediary it's
fine okay well thank you again again
thanks appreciate all the time truly
yeah if if people want to know anything
about Bashar they can go to bashar.org
find all the stuff he's talking about if
they want to know what I'm doing they
can uh go to boggled escaper
rooms.com because we're now getting out
of film and doing Escape rooms for
people to help them transform by having
an adventure okay cool I'm have to check
it out thank you so much I appreciate it
thanks darl thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today I hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the Subscribe
button